CBS News is learning more about a
possible connection between George Floyd
and the former police officer charged
with second degree murder in his death
David Penney a co-worker of Floyd and
Derek Chauvin at a Minneapolis nightclub
told our Jeff PJ's the two had a history
he said when they work security what
kind of history they bumped heads how it
has a lot to do with with Derek being
extremely aggressive within the club
with some of the Patriots which is which
was an issue Jeff Pegues joins us now
from Minneapolis with more on this part
of the story Jeff what else are we
learning about this well good morning
Gail David Penney and many others are
aware of George Floyd and Derek Chauvin
working at the same time at this
nightclub Chauvin was on the outside
working a detail and then George Floyd
worked on the inside now penny as you
noted was a co-worker also working on
that security detail and he told me that
the two men butted heads he also
described Chauvin as being in his words
aggressive toward minority customers now
penny also tells me if the manager of
the club will hand out pay checks to the
security staff on the inside people like
George Floyd and it was then their job
to then pay the outside staff people
like Derek Chauvin and in one occasion
according to David Penney and another
person we talked to Chauvin took issue
with how much he was being paid and
blamed George Floyd who had handed him
the check all right so they had a beef
in your view at least one time over
money exactly but it's not George's
responsibility of what he receives his
pay for moonlight
that's the managers job from the from
the club but Derek took it out on George
exactly as what I understand at the time
yes because he took it out against me
and I actually made him leave the house
I had to make him leave the club so is
there any doubt in your mind that that
Monday
Derek didn't know who George was I'd say
he knew him you think he knew George was
yes any doubt in your mind that he knew
who George was no no doubt my mind he
knew exactly who George was so we also
spoke with the club owner who said that
she was not aware of any payroll issues
but she also described Derek Chauvin is
being aggressive toward minority
customers and there is another issue she
said that you know she didn't want to
complain to the police department about
show Vince behavior because she felt if
she complained she would get someone
worse than Derek Chauvin because in her
words Chauvin was one of the good cops
in the precinct so she didn't want him
being replaced with another cop that she
thought would be a bully Gail hey Jeff
if what mr. penny is saying is true and
he does seem very adamant about it what
does it mean is this significant it's
significant because investigators will
try to figure out what was in Derek
Chauvin mind at the time this incident
here occurred was there some sort of
intent I mean if you look at that video
there are a lot of people who are
wondering why did he keep pressing his
knee against George Floyd's neck and so
they have according to our sources asked
the same questions did the two men know
each other they are aware that the two
men worked at that club at the same time
all right Jeff thank you very much